une sont maintenant conversation avec
madame fernande quentin qui se trouve à
la grande digue
c'est tout nouveau brunswick et le nom
indique bien sûr l'endroit approximatif
le long de la côte canadienne la côte
est canadienne où elle se trouve en ce
moment dans le trentin bonsoir 3 alors
grande digue est ce que vous savez en
quelle année on a appelé ça la grande
digue pour très longtemps
ça doit être au début du 20e siècle au
début vous nous avez posé une question
sur l'histoire du canada il a fallu
remonter aux origines qu'il est
exactement votre question à connaître
l'histoire de jeanne mance infirmières
daic qui a laissé son pays la france
pour venir colonisé j'ai cru comprendre
la nouvelle france serait arrivé si oui
alors maisonneuve
heymans venons qui commence par m et si
vous retenez ça vous avez les débuts de
l'histoire de montréal a aussi fait 116
141 vous avez à ce moment-là 741 les
premiers navires qui quitte la france
pour aller créer une nouvelle ville il y
en avait déjà une qui existaient qui
s'appelait trouver québec fondée en
quelle année au québec
exactement bonne mémoire on vient de
célébrer le 400e
c'était la seule grosse ville y en avait
une autre française autres villes
françaises dans votre coin en acadie
est-ce que c'est à dire ah ben ça se
termine par police à l'époque annapolis
voilà alors c'était 2 les deux villes si
vous voulez à ce moment-là française sur
la côte mais à l'intérieur des terres
n'y avait pas encore de ville c'est à
dire que québec se trouve à l'embouchure
du fleuve saint-laurent et si vous
pénétrer à l'intérieur des terres il ya
une île qui s'attelle aujourd'hui
montréal
et on a pensé à ce moment là il y avait
déjà des colons français qui était venu
au début du set en 1 502 il était
débarqué sur l'île de montréal il s'est
dit c'est à dire ce sera un bel endroit
pour créer une ville puisqu'elle se
trouve au confluent de quelques rivières
dont il ya beaucoup de circulation
d'amérindiens qu'il pourrait nous
apporter des peaux d'animaux
on pourrait faire du commerce
l'important commerce qui serait
profitable à la france la couronne donc
mais on paie plusieurs années et il faut
évidemment avoir des investisseurs c'est
un projet privé mais sanctionné par le
roi mais le roi dit je vois pas quand
même tout payer vous allez faire le tour
des nobles et voir qui veut contribuer
les jésuites notamment ont voulu
contribuer et on a envoyé donc une
expédition qui est arrivé à la ville de
québec en 741 on a passé l'hiver à
québec et en 142 on arrive à montréal où
se ce combat on va appeler le sa ville
marie un la ville de marie et il fait
partie de l'équipe donc madame ans
jeanne mance et maison à ce moment là on
est entouré par des amérindiens quoi
desiro quoi nous avait appris son
envolée oublié dans les livres
d'histoire des jeunes québécois
aujourd'hui les iroquois font partie des
premières nations et on en dit du bien
sauf qu'a eu quelques tensions tension
qui pouvait amener les colons à perdre
leur scalp et c'est ce qu'a connu jeanne
mance c'était une des trois femmes
seulement dans cette folle équipée qui
venait créer une ville ville-marie
lahoud où je vous parle pour ça qu'elle
est passée à l'histoire parce qu'elle
est la demande et de la bravoure et en
plus de ça cette femme là non seulement
elle était elle avait elle avait
commencé physiquement elle était de fait
très forte elle était aussi très bien
connecté politiquement elle est
retournée en france une coupe d'occasion
en a fait partie de nos missions pour
retourner en france en compagnie
maisonneuve pour aller chercher de
l'argent dit sionnel pour certains
projets et vous savez ce que jeanne
mance à crier et le rayonnement rien
c'est l'hôtel dieu sait pas c'est pas un
hôtel c'est un
hôpital n'est ce pas on l'appelait la
maison de ma mère me demande seulement
ce jusqu'au début jusqu'a fin du de la
vie de jeanne mance à des mortes en 773
jusqu'à la fin on était toujours en
période de guerre ou de y avait des
accalmies des fois mais on a toujours l
a toujours connu la guerre avec les
iroquois ce n'est que trente ans plus
tard qu'il ya eu presque 30 ans plus
tard qu'on a signé une paix il ya bien
une histoire fameuse au sujet de mes
notes maisonneuve qui a eu l'audace
monnaie il a mis là il a eu connaissance
qu'il y avait des iroquois qui traînait
ou qui rôdaient autour est tout seul il
est allé de l'autre côté de la palissade
avec un revolver il a tiré quelques
coups de feu et tous les tous ceux qui
étaient restés à l'intérieur du fort
c'est à dire mais il va y passer ils
volent mais il est extrêmement courageux
un moment donné il ya un iroquois qui
s'élance vers lui avec pour l'heure avec
une commune à personne
une hache pour le scalper et lire quoi
est lui tombé dans les bras et par un
tour je ne sais trop comment on s'est
tous les gens qui observaient la scène
dit ça y est il est mort il a réussi à
maîtriser les roquois et à le tuer de
ses propres brad avec cette force
il était fort c'est lui le fondateur de
la ville de montréal et avec lui cette
jeanne mance 7
on peut parler d'une héroïne parce que
c'est occuper de tous les blessés de
toutes les personnes qui avaient besoin
d'aidé c'est souvent les colons au
départ c'était dur d'affronter l'hiver
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour jeannot
parce que étant infirmière et moi qui
vous remercie stéphane vous nous avez
raconter une belle histoire
je vais aller faire mes lectures alors
voilà c'est un de nos auditrices à la
grande digue au nouveau brunswick
madame fernande quentin